the Joe Rogan experience so if someone
orders a steak are you cooking steak are
you sending them a sticker sending them
prepackaged cryovac steaks on the
Withings with instructions that you know
everybody like Star State cooked
differently so we give general
guidelines and pro tips of how to rest
and you know right we send them salsa
verde and we send them C you know steak
salt and what not so are you telling
them to cook on a frying pan like how
are you how are you getting them to cook
it um high heat either the grill or in
the frying pan just high heat is your
thing hi he man high heat and then just
intervals high heat take it off let it
rest high heat take it off so you cook
more especially the t-bones so when you
do that so you're you're not doing it in
one shot you're you're kicking it a
little bit and then let's link up to an
hour to cook like a 35 ounce t-bone
really absolutely why do you bring up
the temperature very slow and gradual
Inc but you're doing it with high heat
yeah in these grow why high heat because
you that's all you got in restaurants
high heat low and slow typically for
brazing but if you're dealing with dry
heat it should be violent it should be
quick and then let it rest especially a
t-bone you got to start the t-bone on
the actual bone right so vertical start
it on you oh yeah Trager yeah that's how
you do it you start our bone so that the
heat can radiate gently through the bone
and out towards the meat so if you just
throw the t-bone on side and then sign
it you have a part that's connected to
that actual t-bone the separation poem
it's gonna be raw and everything else is
gonna be medium and medium rare but if
you start it on the bone the heat is
gently radiated through the meat so that
way through we take the the filet mignon
off and cook the New York side a little
longer
oh so how long do you make it sit on the
bone how long do you have it stacked
vertically like that like 10 to 12
minutes oh wow I've never even thought
of that
yeah man oh he's Decca Fiorentina the
master is Dario who's that Dario
Cecchini
he's one he's like the most famous you
should look him up
one of the most famous butchers in all
of Italy he quotes Dante's [ __ ]
maniac but I went to his restaurant I
think two years ago two designs Florence
it's in I want to say Oh
what's good Dario look at them yeah I
mean that face amazing so happy yeah you
say he's a wild man he's a wild man but
he starts the the t-bone on the bone so
he's oh Jesus my stars that [ __ ]
absolute master that's preposterous
absolute master and so you learn from
him so what I did not learn from him I
you know I've been we've been cooking
you know I've been cooking for 20 years
so you pick things up along the way
cookies just like like anything else
like a practice okay you got a doctor
you got a lawyer right you learn the
fundamentals and then throughout your
career you upgrade those fundamentals
with new and relevant techniques or laws
or whatever cooking is the same thing
you get a foundation and then you
upgrade new and relevant techniques and
so are you using a grill that uses wood
are you cooking on wood yeah we're
cooking on California almond and and
white oak almond almond almond for the
smoke cuz it it'll go to fire like that
because it's so saturated with almond
oil and then oak for long and slow
cooking so it's burned super hot so the
the almond burns really quick and the
oak burns very slow and so you put
different woods in four different times
like yeah so we you started off with you
start with almond and then we add oak
and then we add almond and then we add
oak and it's just kind of fire
maintenance is 90 percent of wood fire
cooking so it's just about how hot it
burns in the distance and I'll bet deep
the coal bed is and how you know evenly
disperse the heat is will have a cool
side and a hot side and then a fireside
all within like a you know 2 square feet
is there images of your grill set up
maman I don't think know Evan your
10-percent technique right now is not
sounding like 10% if you're cooking it
sounds a collage right yeah how could
that be Tara's on you
rotating the fatty 10% hmm so did you
set up this grill this way because like
you that's the only way you cook steak
you prefer to cook it over wood or the
design of Felix the actual shoebox of a
kitchen that we have is really you know
the design was based on the restrictions
of the size so we've crammed a hell of a
lot into I think it's just just under
220 square feet something like that
there's a [ __ ] pizza oven and there's
wood fire grill oh wow burners as a
fryer then you cook at 500 meals a night
in that mm-hmm I think top end is like
350 350 people so a few times that by
three or four different different plates
per person Wow some more than that
it's built for speed I build restaurants
for speed
[Applause]